Hello, everybody, my name is Markiplier
and welcome back to Spooky's House of Jumpscares.
Now, we're at room 100 in endless mode.
We've seen one-
I believe one new monster.
But I didn't even get a good look at it
so I have no idea what it actually was
and we have four more to go
plus the other monsters that were part of Karamari Hospital
And I vaguely remember someone saying that I actually didn't see
all of them, because there was another part of Karamari Hospital that I didn't get to, right?
It was a pretty interesting DLC, I mean I don't-- *weak jumpscare*
(._.) Hi.
How are you doin'? That was a moderately tame entrance for you.
So I don't know exactly if I saw absolutely every part of it, but
I believe, you know, considering the original game
we saw the actual very end of the game,
*jumpscare* we just-
>:I Goodness gracious, man!
Calm down.
Like, we saw the actual end of this game and--- that's new..
*creepy breathing*
Should I worry about the breathing?
I mean- I know I should worry about all the sounds.
Oh, this is an ominous hallway. :O
Okay, it's fine.
Yeah, the way they change up things, like I believe that they changed it up so
that there's more randomly generated stuff and they mix
and match like the textures.
Cause when they made endless mode, I'm pretty sure they
would've put some randomness to it considering
*slightly markipliered* it's just going to be non-stop environments as far as the eye could see.
Which is fanciful and free and I don't mind it either way but
even so,
I have no idea what we'll be doing.
So, I'll be back once we see something new.
Uh, oh!
Ohh, God!
Oh God!
*rumble*
Oh, what's that?
*rumbling continues*
I don't know what that is!
Yueherhh
Oh, okay,  have we see- OOHHHH
HI.
Oh!
Am I still moving?
Am I still moving- f- ooookay.
Guess we're done with that now.
Hiiii, to-do list, I don't need you right now.
I vaguely remember something- euuull
Yeah, I definitely remember the blood door.
That's a nice blood door, oh boy.
Man, why do I put myself through this stuff?
Why do I keep coming back here? Oh, no.
Oh no.
Oh no x2
Oh no x3
Oh no x4
Where am I? Oh, God.
Oohhh God,
Ooohh no.
Oo
Oo,
oo, (a little bit higher than the last one)
oO, (more frantically)
OO, Ooh!
I heard it creepin'!
OOoo, I heard it creepy.
Oo, I heard it creepy creepin'.
Oh- HII
HII
TRIPLE HI
HAI?
Oh man, this is making me sick
Oh god, I hope I'm going in the right way, I can't see.
Is that it? Oh god, I can't see!
Ohhh no, oh, I CAN'T
Where am I? OhHH NO, I can't see!
I actually, honestly can't see.
HEYY, DOOR.
Holy shit!
I'm me- I WAS LOST.
Oh man, this is awful.
This is AWHful,
*double* this is AWHful.
Oh jeezus, AWHFUL
Okay, thank you- can this be over, please?
Can I be done with this?! *on the brink of crying*
Just- are we out of the- nope, we are not out of it yet.
Oh, jeezums.
I'm almost to 150- I'm almost to one-fifty
If I can get to one-fifty I'll be able to- WHAT IS THIS?
What happened here?
What was auh- what was wruh- is that intentional??
What?
Ugh.
Tha- that messes with my brain!
The hell did they do there?
Okay, and 150, okay! We made it.
*save beep*
Bada bing, bada boom. Hello, old recycled art.
[Reading] Day four: Alright I am tired of this place. Today a scary slime man
[Reading] attacked me (sort of) and I ran awway.
I ran "wawy". Okay,
So, that was an awfully difficult fifty levels there because
they really did make that like, nearly impossible to do, like
they- they put extra long levels and then the wind-y
ones I could not tell where the hell I was going, if it didn't return to
reality, I never would've been able to find my way out of there.
And I would've died.
So hopefully these next fifty levels are going to be a bit more forgiving but
I have a feeling they're not gonna.
So, mm.
*squeaky door is squeaky*
[Reading] Day 4: I wish I had Wi-Fi here. That remains the scariest aspect
[Reading] of all in this place. "Palce".
[Reading] I can't check my online profiles or post my daily thoughts.
[Reading] It is making me build up tension.
OoOoh no, you don't have-
have a place to outlet all the-
inane bull shit like I do!
[Reading] Day 6: So I'm pretty much ded now. I don't think I can on
[Reading] and I know the world will miss me, but don't worry wolrd.
[Reading] I am still pretty hardcore for making it this long I suppose but it was a frightful journey (kinda).
*laughs* Oof, that's- that's really self aware, and
hilarious.
So hilarious, you can see how much I'm laughing about it.
Ha ha hee hee hoo hee.
Oo.
[Reading] Day 7: While I am at the end of my ropes I shall press on anyway.
[Reading] I have been eating the last of the cheese curds and haven't found any new food.
[Reading] There is something down the hallway I believe, it's getting closer. OH
[Reading] whyy. Why has this has to happen to me?
Well, your grammAr- your grammar improved,
your grandma improved, too.
But your grammar is much better.
I don't know how that's happening.
Maybe those cheese curds are going straight to your brain.
*scary noise*
Uh-
Okay, that's a different guy, that's uh, the exploration video. OOhh it's
SliMey
Mmmmm
Lovely.
Least we know how to deal with slimey.
So I think it's like, one new monster every fifty levels. *nope*
Which is not too terribly bad and I can manage through.
Huuh duh duh de duh, only go down- we already read that one
Okay, so the next one will be something new. *Monster stomach growling*
Well, that's a new sound.
*Monster noise*
What is that?
What's the rumbly wumbly??
Why does there need to be rumbly wumblies over here?
I thought this was a rumble and/or wumbly free zone! *minor disorted hissing jumpscare*
Sounds like a helicopter going through my brain.
Okay..
I guess we're fin- okay.
I guess, we're fine, okay!
We got through Slimey so quickly, I don't anything else had the chance to think
about what it was gonna do.
And man, these have been much easier, much more short
uh, levels than the last one which is very kind of this game.
Surprisingly kind of this game.
Okay.
So we made it to 200! *save beep*
Shocking!
[Reading] Hey guys, so there are weird cardboard pop outs comin' out everywhere.
[Reading] I guess this was or is a theme ride or some sort. I just keep going down it but I don't have much
[Reading] choice. All in all it's not that bad.
[Reading] Go Team! Kill the other team, get the sphere,
*laughing* Beat the game.
Okay.
Knows about much- much about sports as I do.
Okay, so we're gonna blast through the next 50 levels and hopefully
not die.
I wonder what monster we're gonna get this time.
*Loud Pixelated bell sounds*
WOOAH KAY, we started off
*eggplant!* WONDERFUUU-
WOAAH WOAH WOAH WOAH
WHAT IS THAT?
Did we get that before?
WOAH- woah woah, I don't like that.
Okay.
So far, not threatening.
I hope.
Okay, now it's quiet.
Okay, that's...an interesting choice.
*Cockroach crawls*
AH now it's loud!
Euuh
Oh don't like that- OHH I don't like that!
I know something's gonna happen.
*scream?*
Fuck off, cup of coffee! You piece of shit!
Okay, this fine, this fine- HEY!
IT'S IMSCARED- IT'S IMSCARED
OOO IT'S "IMSCARED".
OOo IT'S "IMSCARED".
OO, IT'S "IMSCARED" ALL OVER AGAIN.
OO.
That was the face from Is- "ImScared", the white face.
Woah, that was so "ImScared", I haven't seen that in yyeeearrss.
I haven't seen that in yeEEAaarRRs. Like,
holy SHIT!
WuHEY!- go away, go away.
Go away, go away. Ooohhh go away.
Oh my god, I haven't even thought about that in- I'm dying, why am I dying?
W-w- am I
Why am I dying?
I f- I d- I don't know!
EUUGHH
Why am I dying?
Why is there blood...vines hanging from the ceiling?
Ughh I don't like this.
Oh- b-d- nunununununuNyahnunununununununuNyaAHnunununu
NYAHnunununununununoooo.
Ah! Shit.
What do I do? AHH
I got by him.
I got by him somehow, I don't know how, but I got by him.
If I don't get stuck on any of the walls.
Ewwh, I need more sprint. Where's my axe? *you have it*
Wait a minute- wait!
I b- I
I've been stuck on room 227 forever!
*girly scream*
I've been stuck on room 227, and I didn't even notice that.
How the FUCK?
What do I do?
What do I do? *Have a Marky burger?*
*quadruple* What do I do?
What do I do?
I.. how could I not notice that?
WHATT?
So it was just a matter of persistence? *apparently*
What is thIS? *a hallway*
WHAT IS THIS? *it's... it's a room*
WHat is this new bull shit? *purple?*
What is this music? *ooh, THAT*
Whyistheremusic playin?
isanyofthis necessary?
*more door squeakiness*
Oh, okay, 228.
[Reading] So everybody, everything is decent at least.
[Reading] Food is almost gone, water too. At the least the foundation of this place seems to be
[Reading] holding and there isn't much mold in the air so I don't have to use my mask.
[Reading] I still want to get out of here soon.
What the hell was that?
Man. Oh, hi. *hello*
That was a time sync, that's what that was. Wow!
But yeah, Imscared, holy shit, I-
that was one of the earliest horror games I ever played.
[Reading] Well readers, I found a greenhouse or garden area.
[Reading] It was pretty neat but it didn't help me much.
[Reading] I did find a cool sickle thing in a 'tree'.
[Reading] I normally don't steal from the places I explore but I have this really uneasy vibe
[Reading] from this place and I want something to defend myself.
*sarcastic* I'm sure you do. *says the man asking for "his* axe earlier*
Man.
that was nuts.
God, that brought me back, too, because I thought about the other, like
horror games that I've played because "ImScared" started a lot of pixelated horror games.
And I guess, this one could be considered a pixelated horror game, but
there's a very specific style that like, "ImScared" started.
Man.
[Reading] Hey everyone, I wish my cameras had battery left.
[Reading] I found some really cool areas of this building.
[Reading] Some looked like a school of sorts and another looked like it must have been
[Reading] a house restaurant. I found some frozen meat there, but I'm not sure if I should attempt
[Reading] to eat it or not.
Yeah, probably. I mean, what's the worst that could happen?
Oh, boy.
More changes.
No time for this, I'm almost at the end.
Unless it's gonna stick me at 249 for a long time.
Wait- whay? It- whay- it skipped right by 250! *no, the painting!*
*creepy deep laughter*
Huh HOH huh huhhhuhhhh
Uhdh duh huhH huh.
What's so funny?
The fact that I have to go to 300 now to get a checkpoint?
Sonavabiatch.
*deep laughter*
Haha, hohooho, HEEHE. HAHAHO WOHAHA.
HEeheehee.
Hahahahaha.
Hoho.
What's gonna happen?
Ugh, what was that?
Egh. I don't like this. Something's gearing up for me.
Is it behind me?
Woa- hey!
Hi!
What the hell are you?
*laughing* What is that?
It's a giant beaver! *otter*
Okaay.
It's- *it's an otter, Mark*
I- I don't- I honestly don't know what to say about that.
It- it's literally a giant beaver. *otter*
Okay.
Oh jeez, it's getting faster!
Oh, shit. Shouldn't have looked behind, it's getting faster.
Oh, boy.
Ooookay.
Don't do that, nonono.
I am fast enough to get away from you, I wanna be shm- I wanna believe.
Egh
You still back there?
Okay. Got away from the murderous, giant beaver. *otter*
Don't know why I need-
Was that more? Is he back? Is he still there?
Oh, shit.
Oh, no.
Is he actually still there? Because that's something that I need to worry about.
Okay..
[Reading] Okay guys, I'm done with this place.
[Reading] As interesting as it may be I think I actually might be in life threatening danger here.
[Reading] I can't imagine it going on much longer and I've gone way too far down to get back up now.
Okay. So why'd you keep goin' down? Obviously there's not gonna be an exit if you go down.
It's just gonna be nonstop into the ground.
Dummy.
OOh! WhyY? I'm almost OOUTT.
I'M alMOST DOneEE.
I hope so
If it doesn't give me a checkpoint, then I'm just fubbernucked.
Oh, that's- that's a deep rumble.
That's a deep bassy- please.
YES.
OKAY!
Thank you! *save beep*
Oh, boy.
Wow, bunnee. Okay.
Abaddon incarnate.
[Reading] Well readers, I think I'm near an exit. I found another mansion like area.
[Reading] I feel really tired so I'm going to take a break here.
Okay!
So anyway, I'm also gonna take a break here.
So, thank you everybody so much for watching,
I don't know how many new ones still remain, but it's gonna be interesting to see, and so thanks again, everybody,
and as always, I will see you
in the next video!
Buh-Bye!
*outro music*